this video is brought to you by full
sail university
what's up guys michael here and today
i'm ready to inspire a niche group of
otherwise charming adults to write me
ever more elaborate death threats
welcome to part two of our exploration
of disney adulthood where mouse ears are
part of the lifestyle and reciting
hakuna matata each morning is mandatory
last time we looked at the scholarly
debate over how we talk about fandoms
like disney and whether or not they
qualify as religion and despite the fact
that it might make some scholars and all
disney adults very very mad at us we're
going to take it a step further today
we're going to examine the evidence for
disney operating as a religion that
means looking at the nuts and bolts of
how the hypothetical church of mickey
mouse works and what its spiritual
doctrine might entail so buckle up for
part two of this wisecrack edition on
disney adults is disney a religion
but before we get into it i want to
shout out this video sponsor full sail
university full sail offers associates
bachelors and master's degrees in the
fields of technology arts media and
entertainment and they just launched a
new bachelor's degree in game business
and esports which can help students
enter the industry from different
perspectives from game development to
communications and marketing to
competitive gaming itself and this new
major joins a roster of other cool
fields of study like film production
computer animation sportscasting and web
development with full sail university's
accelerated coursework you can finish
your degree in about half the time
required at other colleges and
universities plus you can complete your
classes and coursework online or in
person at full sales campus in orlando
depending on what's right for you
whatever model you choose you'll get
hands-on real-world experience in the
career path of your choice plus full
sale accepts new enrollments monthly so
you don't have to build your schedule
around traditional semesters to learn
more about full sail university's new
game business and esports majors or any
of their other degree programs visit
fullsail.edu
wisecrack that's fullsale.edu
wisecrack and now back to the show
remember our friend religious gallery dr
eichler levine whose passionate defense
of disney adults inspired this video
series in the first place well she's far
from the first person to explore the
possibility that disney might constitute
a modern day religion way back in 1934
author iam forster went so far as to
argue that mickey is everybody's gone
meanwhile scholar richard fogelson
called disney the vatican with mouse
ears but in order to really determine if
disney is a full-blown faith we first
need to think about what makes something
a religion to begin with for our
purposes we're going to use
anthropologist clifford gertz's popular
definition from 1973 which outlines five
stipulations to define religion as one a
system of symbols two about the nature
of things three that inculcate
dispositions for behavior for through
ritual and cultural performance five so
that the conceptions held by the group
are taken as real addressing the first
piece a system of symbols look no
further than mickey mouse himself who
has become a world wide symbol of
innocence in the united states market
researchers have found he has a 97
recognition rate making him more
recognizable than santa claus as
cultural critic henry jero notes the
cultural iconography of disney renders
it a purveyor of innocence and family
fun he adds that through its films parks
and endless merchandising disney becomes
a symbol for the security and romance of
the small town america of yesteryear
from the iconic cinderella's castle
representing enchantment and dreams
coming true to barbershop quartets
strolling down main street usa disney is
rife with symbolism not unlike that of
religion
they do some of this by operating as
what depaul university professor michael
buddy might call symbolic predators that
is appropriating existing imagery from
traditional religions indeed like the
sun shining over simba's kingdom echoes
of world religions appear throughout
disney properties take the concept of
the circle of light which is deeply
rooted in hinduism according to
journalist mark pinsky or snow white
taking a bite from an apple like you
know who
heck epinsky points out that in
pinocchio when geppetto falls to his
knees to ask an undefined deity for help
a fairy appears conveniently decked out
in the virgin mary's trademark shade of
blue still let's be clear explicit
references are largely absent from
disney movies this was intentional
disney biographer bob thomas notes that
walt disney made the strategic business
decision to keep religion out of his
films in order to make them marketable
to the widest international audience and
yet there's still an argument to be made
for the second qualification for
religion about the nature of things
disney movies may not feature an
explicit god figure but many have argued
that disney effectively poached a lot of
judeo-christian ideology while scrubbing
out the actual divinity stuff as pinsky
explained back in 2004 there is
relatively little explicit
judeo-christian symbolism or substance
in 70 years of disney's animated
features despite the frequent almost
pervasive use of a theological
vocabulary words such as faith belief
miracle blessing sacrifice and divine it
seems a contradiction for train
consistent judeo-christian values
without sectarian or even godly context
the fruits without the roots
he points out that disney effectively
preaches the protestant work ethic minus
the whole god thing exemplifying the
argument that hard work leads to upward
social mobility no matter what echoes of
the david and goliath story frequently
pulsate through the films with the poor
and downtrodden always eventually
triumphing over the powerful and corrupt
as pinsky summarizes good is always
rewarded evil is always punished faith
is an essential element faith in
yourself and even more faith in
something greater than yourself some
higher power optimism and hard work
complete the basic canon pinsky dubs
this disney ethos secular tunisim
explaining that in place of god working
as divine magic disney uses magical
creatures doing magic magic you know
berries and fairy godmothers genies and
ice queens sea witches and
land witches in this way scholar kathy
murlock jackson writes magic becomes a
way to empower the powerless just like
god does in so many classic biblical
stories so part 2 pretty much checks out
part 3 inculcating dispositions for
certain behaviors we're going to set
aside for now and return to momentarily
so we've established that disney
essentially created and maintained a
consistent system of symbols about the
nature of things across its films parks
and other products but how are those
messages imparted onto its believers
well as author richard corliss
speculated in a 1988 issue of time
magazine walt disney's philosophy may as
well have been the jesuit credo of give
me a child before he is seven and he
will be mine for life
indeed disney said as much declaring
that i think of a child's mind as a
blank book during the first years of his
life much will be written on the pages
the quality of that writing will affect
his life profoundly by his own logic
then disney has been for multiple
generations scribbling all over those
blank minds with children spending more
time consuming disney films than they do
with organized religion and of course as
many of us grow out of childhood and
into our teens and adulthood disney is
right there to accompany us on our
journeys except this time with jedis and
superheroes and bounty hunters until
life gets so depressing that we need the
talking animals again and then we come
to part four of our definition ritual
and cultural performance by far the most
salient place where the rituals of
disney consolidate is of course at its
theme parks according to harper's
magazine's index an estimated 70 percent
of americans have been to one of them
which is probably the only thing 70
percent of americans have in common
these larger than life locations are
seen by some scholars as akin to sacred
spaces where visitors make a pilgrimage
not unlike that of jews to jerusalem or
muslims to mecca or american irish
catholics to the guinness brewery at st
james gate dublin fittingly disney
sparks are absent of the unholy
banalities of real life like litter or
swearing or frowning religion scholar
mercedes describes the importance people
of faith ascribe to so-called sacred
spaces i.e places that seem to exist in
a sacred time that is when the world was
young and edenic in these spaces myth
and ritual help worshipers by
recalibrating life toward the divine
as scholars eric mazur and tara kota
summarize in their book the happiest
place on earth notably as drew points
out disney too exist outside of time
hell disney reportedly removed all alarm
clocks from its hotels in 2016 more
importantly the parks have no references
to the present a few references towards
the future but mostly seem to exist in a
past that somehow approximates
eisenhower's conservative america that
is a time when the world was young
indeed disney world was attracting the
nostalgia of baby boomer parents long
before it became the site of their
millennial children's weddings missing
of course is anything unpleasant about
that arrow like the red scare or racism
or barbiturates in frontierland the
american frontier is mythologized as a
place of courage and adventure making
the brutal genocide committed against
native people on those lands a brief
footnote american history is further
glorified and sanitized in places like
the hall of the presidents where ugly
parts of history like say watergate or
iran contra are ignored as an
animatronic abe lincoln and christlike
glory returns to life
historian mike wallace calls this
commercialization of the past mickey
mouse history a narrative written
without classes conflict or crime a
world of continuous consumption a
supermarket of fun innocence effectively
becomes a magic eraser cleansing history
of its less savory moments and these
disney narratives all come to life in
its holy sites where rituals like ride
and splash mountain or watch in sunset
parades down main street or get your
picture taken with the characters for a
hefty feat all provide joy and catharsis
in these spaces religious scholar peter
gardeller writes magical beings like
tinkerbell and mickey mouse abound and
many shows imply that such beings might
help ordinary people gardella calls this
transtheism or the provisional
acceptance of many gods with an implied
underlying oneness as with a religious
service your sense of possibilities for
your life are expanded through promises
of divine intervention or at least the
ear of a sympathetic fairy godmother
giroud describes disney as a privatized
homogenous and risk-free city whereas
critic elaine wrapping points out no
trace of anything non-commodified
non-simulated non-regulated
non-smiley-faced is visible or reachable
as with other sacred sites the sense of
effortless magic is facilitated as much
by what you don't see as by what you do
a tour of the pope's bathroom might kind
of ruin the vibe of the vatican after
all
similarly there's a virtual absence of
anything non-magical at disney most
especially visible labor disney
employees sorry um we mean cast members
use underground tunnels to transport
food products and waste as gero
concludes through the use of public
visual space i.e parks like magic
kingdom disney's network of power
relations promotes the construction of
an all-encompassing world of enchantment
allegedly free from ideology politics
and power
that's in spite of the fact that
political lobbying is the reason the
disney world was able to exist for so
long as a self-governing independent
special district the park paints itself
as a place of transcendence of elevation
beyond the mundanity of everyday life
which brings us to stipulation 5 so that
the conceptions held by the group are
taken as real now we're obviously not
saying that disney adults literally wish
upon stars or work hard at their jobs
just because seven dwarves of various
dispositions told them to but disney's
grand narrative of spiritual uplift
moral truth and endless nostalgia
seems to be taken at face value or
filtered through the fervor with which
disney adults express themselves disney
adults may not pay sedaka at the temple
of tinkerbell but one popular disney
world vacation tip site suggests that
two adults have to cough up between 1900
and 2 800 to visit disney which i'd call
a healthy tithe
meanwhile according to the washington
post disney continues to hike prices as
much as five to ten percent each year
which is fine because wages go up at the
same rate right that's how economics
work viewing disney world as a site for
rights of passage like weddings or bar
and bat mitzvahs cements the sense of
faith fans have in the sanctity of its
ethos
now let's return to stipulation number
three inculcating dispositions for
behavior what if any sort of behavior
does the disney empire encourage in its
supplicants you might be surprised
actually that we haven't really brought
it up yet starts with c synonym for eat
that's right consumption and lots of it
as american studies scholar eric smuden
puts it disney constructs childhood so
as to make it entirely compatible with
consumerism and it does so in the hopes
of creating lifelong patrons of disney
entertainment and related products
though it's not the only company to
attempt such a feat missouri and coda
argue that because of its market
penetration its integrated marketing and
its access to many levels of culture
through its corporate network disney is
uniquely suited for the religion of its
commodity this is important because as
jerome notes in our world of rapidly
evolving mass communication pop culture
is a central way for young people to
learn about themselves their
relationship to others and the larger
world he argues that disney is perfectly
suited for a world where democracy has
come to be less defined by civic
engagement than by the freedom to
consume freely and be entertained disney
he explains prime children to relate to
themselves as consumers before citizens
as individuals pursuing self-interest
rather than members of communities
pursuing any sort of collective good and
then carry that self-perception into
adulthood nowhere is this more evident
than a disney world where as jarrow
explains consumption becomes the
unifying force through which families
organize themselves disney theme parks
not only provide middle class families
with an upbeat version of the american
past they give such entertainment the
force of civic duty encouraging
spectatorship and passivity disney
appropriates nostalgia simply to
maximize consumption in the interest of
fun and commerce all with the side of
mickey mouse popsicles of course now
given disney's ability to fulfill all
five stipulations of gertz's definition
of religion it's easy to conclude that
it is in fact functioning like a
religion even if unintentionally but
there's still a bit more to unpack see
most religions ask us to sacrifice
things in exchange for say salvation or
god's good graces we're supposed to give
our money to houses of worship or
charities or spend part of our weekends
in prayer or deny ourselves the pleasure
of red meat or avoid masturbating so the
pope doesn't show up to our house and
glue our palms to a cross religions also
typically ask us to strive to abide by
an ethical code and repent when we fail
to do so but disney's pitch is a bit
more simple as phil fisher co-founder of
veggie tales persuasively argues disney
has wrapped up and sold america what
people wanted to hear which was give us
the upside of religion without the
obligation of religion that is like a
lot of businesses disney offers us
enlightenment through consumption
without asking us to do any of the pesky
self-examination that traditional
religion might require the difference is
they just happen to have a lot more
power and of course a lot more real
estate than most of the other people
trying to sell you
at their parks we can enjoy all the
spiritual and ecstatic feeling of
religious worship without having any of
the moral or ethical responsibility that
religion imposes upon us disney's
ideology is ultimately
pretty hollow and yet its cultural reach
is so expansive its appeals to childhood
innocent so persuasive that we can
easily forget it's not a value-driven
benevolent entity striving to uplift its
followers it's a profit-driven
multinational corporation
as giroux puts it innocent serves as a
rhetorical device that cleanses the
disney image of the messiness of
commerce ideology and power that is to
say marketing itself as an institution
in the business of enchantment can make
you forget the immense and ever-growing
chokehold over the entertainment
industry and it's obviously not just
preaching the gospel of mickey for fun
as giroux furthers that disney has a
political stake in creating a particular
moral order favorable to its commercial
interest raises questions about what it
teaches he argues that the lesson plans
at the school of disney ultimately
reinforce an infantilized and privatized
notion of citizenship disney probably
isn't consciously trying to mimic
religion but its approach to converting
acolytes can border on indistinguishable
let us repeat disney is not trying to be
a religion but its tactics and the
reception it receives from fans
often takes on a spiritual tinge
disney's interests are well served when
people buy its products but its
interests are best served when a
consumption driven population is more
concerned with having fun at disney
world than say
with the labor rights of the workers
making the park happen in the first
place or the company's serial cover-ups
of sexual harassment and assault in our
cynical day and age we all pretty much
know that giant corporations basically
never become giant corporations because
they've done things in kind and
magnanimous ways no matter how cute
their mascot is and disney is no
different while it's been hosting gay
days since 1991 under the auspice of
celebrating the queer community it was
also just recently busted for donating
money to politicians who oppose queer
rights that includes florida republican
dennis baxley a career-long champion of
anti-gay legislation and sponsor of the
controversial don't say gay bill which
limits school teachers from mentioning
anything queer-related in the classroom
while claiming to be a pride friendly
company they've simultaneously been
funding politicians who are actively
harming the queer community now after
public outcry disney ceo bob chapek
eventually spoke out against the bill
promising to be a better ally and
announce that the company was pausing
political donations in florida yet
concurrently queer pixar workers
published a statement claiming that
disney higher ups insisted they cut
nearly every moment of overtly gay
affection in their films suggesting the
company's allyship remains
suspect and this is hardly the first of
disney's questionable political
affiliations they've also funded
business groups who actively fight
climate change legislation and a recent
report found that 69 of their political
donations went to anti-abortion
politicians it's rainbow capitalism at
its most insidious or take the time in
2013 as disney was developing the movie
coco when they tried to trademark the
phrase
dia de los muertos this is part of
disney's gargantuan merchandising
machine which dates back to 1937 snow
white
you heard that right in the lead up to
the release of their groundbreaking
celebration of mexican culture disney
tried to actively snatch the name of a
sacred tradition out of the hands of the
mexican people across multiple media
platforms it's not good team it's not
good what's more the values of spouse
and disney films over the years can
leave a foul taste in the mouth of a
more progressive culture from blatant
racism to tired tropes of princesses
being rescued by princes disney has long
been a protector of white
heteronormative ideology with much of
the fantasy that makes it so appealing
coming from a longing for an imagined
past of greater simplicity despite
disney's attempts to keep its nostalgia
apolitical there's nonetheless a deeply
political tinge to its evocation of a
better time especially when you remember
that in this romanticized past many
minority groups experienced profound
discrimination and while disney is
certainly getting better about depicting
more diverse stories it's hard to outrun
its legacy especially when those
foundational films and park attractions
remain so popular so it looks like
disney has successfully used aspects of
religion to maintain its cultural power
but that doesn't mean that it's
intentionally built a religion at the
same time it's the epitome of a
capitalist institution and has always
been most loyal to the creed of
maximizing profits so what exactly does
that make it that question like the
historic relationship between capitalism
and religion in america
is more complicated than you might think
dating back to the 16th century
christian missionaries who accompanied
gold hungry explorers on their
excursions to the new world
religious scholar robert lawrence moore
argues that religion has evolved
alongside mass consumer culture out of
necessity increasingly commodifying
along the way he writes that religious
influences established themselves in the
forms of commercial culture that emerged
in the 19th century turning the united
states into a flowering eden of leisure
industries by the middle of the 20th
beginning with various sects
mass-produced and extensive religious
reading materials religions expanded
their wares by entering radio and
theater and eventually television via
televangelists like jim and tammy faye
baker pat robertson and jimmy swaggart
they expanded beyond halls of worship
into non-profits athletic clubs like the
ymca social halls and so on he explains
that by degrees religion itself took on
the shape of a commodity as it looked
for ways to appeal to all consumers
using the techniques of advertising and
publicity at the same time religious
institutions have been notably exempt
from some of the governmental
regulations and limitations of other
markets more notes riley that flashy
neon signs promising jesus saves would
never get churches in trouble for false
advertising after world war ii
commodified religion poured into
american culture at an unprecedented
rate and culture responded in like with
a proliferation of hollywood
blockbusters based on biblical stories
around this time america saw the
beginnings of the mega church which
according to scholar scott thuma
function like corporations with the
pastor as the often handsome and
handsomely compensated ceo they brand
themselves like corporations too by
offering disparate attractive forms of
fun performing arts recreation
activities gyms even movie theaters and
don't even get us started again on the
enormous christian music scene and it
wasn't just christianity from the 60s on
hundreds of new age religions flourished
among free-thinking boomers almost
always with economic tie-ins in the form
of healing spas crystals and radio
stations in this way as sociologist
peter l berger has observed religious
institutions become marketing agencies
and the religious traditions become
consumer commodities and a good deal of
religious activity comes to be dominated
by the logic of market economies in
recent years as missouri and coda note
the line between religious activities
and commercial activities has become
increasingly blurry the unexpected
crossovers between the two realms and
everything from christian mlms to jewish
dating sites increasingly people like
the fourth best hollywood chris will
identify not as religious but as
spiritual a term that is inherently
looser and can be conducive to a sort of
grab bag approach to spirituality mazur
and coda concur writing of disney they
have entered the market at a time when
many people are not only searching for
alternatives to traditional religion but
are also flexible with what they find so
maybe the answer ultimately is that
disney is fulfilling functions of
religion such as religious institutions
fulfill functions like fun and
entertainment that are typically
associated with disney so disney's not
necessarily becoming more like religion
religion might just be becoming more
like disney and nowhere is this bizarre
paradox more apparent than at one of the
country's many jesus themed parks but
then again maybe we shouldn't see this
as strange at all because capitalism as
an economic theory has actually never
been totally free from religion
philosopher walter benjamin famously
said that a religion may be discerned in
capitalism that is to say capitalism
serves essentially to ally the same
anxieties torments and disturbances to
which the so-called religions offered
answers which basically means that
capitalism isn't just an economic system
but a set of beliefs that aims to offer
meaning and purpose to modern life but
rather than offering the hope peace and
justice often promised by religion
according to benjamin capitalism is a
religion which offers us not the reform
of existence but its complete
destruction it is the expansion of
despair until despair becomes a
religious state of the world in the hope
that this will lead to salvation in this
context all kinds of profit driven
institutions could be seen as doing
something similar i.e offering their own
solutions to problems previously thought
to be the realm of religion whether
you're preserving your hello kitty lunch
box behind a wall of glass or worshiping
at the altar of your favorite crossfit
instructor praying with your model hot
pastor at an evangelical megachurch or
spending your whole paycheck at disney's
animal kingdom which why it's the
saddest place in the world because it's
like a zoo but there's there's no way
they're taking care of it the same way
you would take care of a zoo it's really
it makes me feel bad don't go to animal
kingdom no matter what just about every
major institution you're engaging with
is inevitably shining their lights
towards the goodness of our one true god
capital and as for disney adults are
they part of a religion nah not by our
estimations but are they an excellent
example of the porousness between
consumerism and spirituality that
characterizes this moment in time
almost certainly but the good thing is
unless you're the type of person who
uses up all your yearly vacation days
for trips to anaheim in orlando you are
in the clear i guess unless um you're
really into star wars because that's
that's disney now or if you've enjoyed
the 29 or so mcu movies and the growing
number of mcu tv shows which are
produced by disney and available on
disney plus
but hey if you're like a sports person
then you're good except for disney owns
espn so every time you watch steven a
smith lay down a hot take you're still
playing
right into the those the hands of the
mouse oh god um okay at least i still
have my guilty pleasure the bachelor and
it's related properties which
damn it they're on abc which is owned by
disney too jesus christ or
jesus mouse or mickey christ i don't
even know anymore so maybe
we're just all disney adults now whether
we realize it or not
but what do you think do you welcome
your mouse-eared overlord or do we still
have a chance to eke out our own
spiritual identities let us know in the
comments
thanks to our patrons for all your
support be sure to check out our new
patreon perks if you haven't already and
be sure to check out our new stream
wisecrack live that happens right here
every thursday at 11 a.m pacific smash
that subscribe button like it's a bell
jar protecting the enchanted rose
keeping you alive and don't forget to
ring that bell be sure to like this
video unless it's inspired you to write
hate mail and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Music]
you